what do you think is the average age of
a member of Congress is today what would
you say 45 50 52 55 what would you say
the age is when I saw this data I was a
little bit concerned and I said you know
what I want to talk about this to see if
you feel the way I do about this and by
the way when I make my argument to you
if you agree with it give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel so let's
get right into it do you know today only
17 of Americans are above 65 years old
the average age of an American today is
38.6 years old 38.6 but the average age
of a member of Congress today is 60 60
years old I sat there and I said is 60
the average should we have somebody at
that age servant and the member of
Congress I said okay in America a
president the president of the United
States the other title for the president
is commander-in-chief which means what
the leader of our military right should
there be an age to the military leaders
today's sponsor is Aura what Aura does
is protect you against identity theft
which today it is is the fastest growing
crime in all of America just last year
1.5 million Americans experience
identity theft for you know how much
money ready not 1 billion not 5 billion
not 10 billion 52 billion dollars just
last year every 14 seconds somebody's
identity is stolen which means during
this video four to five people's
identity will be stolen and the reason
why this is important to me is I've been
in the financial industry for a long
time Insurance Finance we spend a lot of
money every year to protect against
cyber security attacks just a fun fact
one of our employees Aaron went on their
website and he tested to see how many
times his identity had been stolen his
password over 40 times on the dark web
you may want to find out how many times
your identity has been stolen so if you
want to protect yourself from the
fastest growing crime in America visit
aura.com forward slash value timing to
start your 14-day trial one more time
aura aura.com
forward slash valuetainment to start
your 14-day free trial with aura try
Aura free for two weeks to find that if
any of your personal information or your
family's personal information has been
compromised when I was in the military
there was certain age that you couldn't
join the Army right and those those laws
those numbers are out there so we looked
it up right now and here's what we found
out do you know what is the oldest you
can be in the military before they force
you to be retired ready if you're a
non-non-general in the military you're
forced to retire at 62 years old now if
you're an 0-9 or an o10 which is a
three-star General I believe or a
four-star general you get to stay if you
get an approval till 64.66 but if you
want to stay till 68 you have to get an
approval from Secretary of Defense or
the president of the United States which
rarely happens and that's 68 maximum age
is what we're talking about so now
I said okay how old was uh Obama when he
was a president 47. he became a senator
at 43. Clinton was 46. Trump was 69.
Biden was 78 he's 79 about to be 80.
that's that's old if you think about I'm
not and I'm not saying hey you know
you're calling these people I'm not
saying that all I'm saying is the
following
if the average age of Congress is 60 yet
the military forces people to retire by
62 years old why aren't we forcing
anybody that's 62 years old or hired to
retire today go play a role of a
consultant go play a role of an advisor
but America is Young is 38.4 and they
need the representation to be a little
bit more closer to them so they can
relate to them yes a good age Gap is
good maybe 48.4 is a good average maybe
52 is a good average if America's 38.4
but 60 years old means we got people in
their 70s
that our Congo in Congress today why if
military forces you to retire why
shouldn't we be forcing Congress men and
women who have served their time to
retire this ain't even term limits by
the way although I'm you know for having
term limits in place where these guys
cannot be there for 30 40 years this is
purely about you've done your service
you've reached an age thank you for your
service here's a retirement check go
become a consultant go sit on a board go
do a bunch of different you're going to
make more money anyways maybe some of
you make more money staying in Congress
but you're going to make more money
anyways let's decrease the age from 60
to 55 to 50 maybe to 48. now I may be
delusional I may be wrong if you fully
disagree with me forget about this video
if you agree with me give it a thumbs up
subscribe and share this with others and
let's see what other people say about my
argument
foreign
[Music]